don't worry babe we'll be together
forever
come here
goodbye forever I never really liked him
guess who's a boss and just got into
college oh you're officially enrolled in
only calling your parents when you need
something
I go with college choice number two
because they offered the most financial
aid and they have a 1-2-3 boy-girl ratio
I got all the classes I want it Oh
naptime 101 got it you'll do great at
that I'm gonna pick up all these boxes
to show you that you could still
remember that I'm manly when I start
crying in your dorm room this is the
best room I've ever seen so much space
to be free Annapurna
oh look it's a glorified broom closet
I'm gonna miss you guys just remember
we're gonna keep telling you you're on
your own from now on but we don't
actually mean it don't worry I'll talk
to you guys every time I don't know how
to do something bye
I'll think of an excuse to call her in
five minutes
did you fill out that student loan
application
chill out dad it only takes 15 minutes
you